(man) the sharks are back.
They're looking for the best
products and Businesses
America has to offer.
The only thing that
really matters--what is it?
Money.
Hopeful entrepreneurs come
to the shark tank
seeking an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
(man) We're not asking
for your money for a handout.
We just need
a little bit of work.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
got in over 400 requests
for franchise information.
Love it, baby!
All right, baby. Let's go!
And Fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'm gonna make an offer.
Okay, wait.
Before you make an offer...
wait.
Let me make an offer.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark to invest
the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
We're gonna project
$4.8 million in 2 years.
Get it up!
It's sink...
or swim.
There's nothing proprietary
or unique about this product.
You are gonna get
slaughtered.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made,
filthy rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Barbara Corcoran turned
a $1,000 loan
into a real estate Empire worth
hundreds of millions
in the shark-filled city
of Manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold
his first internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-made
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪♪
My name is Tony Devine,
and I'm from
Bristol, pennsylvania.
My product is going
to revolutionize the way
we train for basketball.
Finish! Finish!
Oh, let's go.
Use that left hand!
I've been a basketball coach
my entire life...
Let's go!
And I always felt like
there was something missing,
and that was the realism
when you practiced.
So one day I'm in the backyard
working out with my son.
The kid is
a very good basketball player,
but there's one thing
that I notice.
He's a great shooter
when Nobody's in his face,
and it hits me.
The lightbulb goes off,
and within a week
I had a ROUGH prototype ready
to bring out onto the court.
And I'm telling you,
within ten minutes
he was shooting better
than He has ever shot before,
so I know I have something that
is going to be huge.
I think the Sharks are gonna
love it.
♪♪♪
How are you guys doing today?
My name is Tony Devine,
and my product is
the original profender.
I'm seeking
a $75,000 investment
for a 15% stake
in my business.
The original profender is
theonly--
let me say that again--
theonlymobile training device
in the world that simulates
a closeout defender.
Since most coaches are
built like me,
kinda sloppy
and out of shape,
it makes it very difficult
for us
to close out on our players
and give 'em a realistic look,
but when you incorporate
the original profender
into any workout,
you're going to make
that coach or that owner feel
like a star again,
because now they're going to be
able to contest every shot.
This is my son Devon.
This is who inspired me
to come up with the idea,
and we're going to show you
exactly why this thing
is going to be in every gym
and on every driveway
in the country.
All right. Here we go.
Boom! Right on you.
Here we go.
It's gonna raise up.
Give me that.
Boom! Here we go.
Get it up!
(grunts)
All right.
Now with your help,
I'm gonna be able to put
the original profender
in the hands
of Every basketball player
around the world
and give them the opportunity
to stop pretending
and start Profending.
Whoo! Love it, baby! Whoo!
All right, baby. Let's go!
All right!
All right.
Let me see if they work.
That's what I like to see.
Now, mark, instead of using
the original profender,
I'm gonna give you...
the originaloffender.
(sharks laughing)
(daymond) ohh!
The original offender.
Now do you sell that
to farms as a scarecrow?
(Kevin) Oh, I love it.
Here we go.
Come on. Here's what you do.
(Barbara) Oh, you guys.
Oh! I'm so sorry!
(sharks laugh)
Here we go. One shot.
Here we go.
I'm gonna need to do
the fadeaway.
Boom!
(cheers and applause)
That was too easy.
I'm gonna give you
the more Younger, virile
original offender.
This is when he had hair
and he was good.
(daymond) Yeah!
(sharks Laughing)
Look at this guy.
Here we go.
Whenever you're ready.
Whenever you're ready,
coach.
Give me that.
Ohh.
There we go.
(Kevin) Ohh.
Okay, wait, wait.
I want to get one more shot,
just 'cause he's so ugly,
I can't let him stop me.
(laughs)
Give me that.
(cheering)
(laughs)
(Robert) Whoo! Tony...
All right.
Is there a product like this
on the market today?
There are other things,
but they're not dynamic.
Well, how do you do it
today, mark?
How do the pros do it?
(chuckles)
the Younger coach puts up
a Broom.
Seriously?
There's value, right.
Having to shoot
over the higher hands--
no question, there's value.
The question is,
is it big enough to be
a big business?
Do you have any sales
of this thing?
I have $25,000 in sales
over the first year,
but I don't want you to get
caught up in that number,
'cause I went to--
oh, you never do,
but, listen,
while we're caught up in it...
Yeah.
Who did you sell them to?
I packed up a truck
with a bunch of my friends.
Anywhere we could drive,
we brought our profenders
and sold them.
I brought this thing to
las vegas for U.S.A. Basketball.
I got this thing down
on the floor.
I'm rolling this
at Kevin Durant.
Kevin Durant says, "This thing
is gonna be big real soon.
I just can't wait to--to be
the first one to buy it."
Butdidhe buy it?
Did he buy it?
Do you know
how impossible it is
to try to get in touch
with these guys?
(sharks laughing)
You had him right there.
They got rid of us.
They kicked us off.
Tony, how much do
they cost?
They cost--right now
they're $499.95.
500 bucks?
They're 500 bucks.
It's 500 bucks
for that thing?
It's 500 bucks.
Mark, you own a team.
Would you pay 500 bucks
for this?
The NBA teams can
afford it.
Probably the bigger division I
schools can afford one,
maybe several.
But the challenge is
once you go beyond there,
because, you know,
your typical family
That's just got, you know,
a pop-up hoop like this
in the driveway,
c-can they afford it?
This is gonna be
a 2-pronged attack.
There's gonna be
the industrial/commercial
That's for the, uh,
basketball pro grades to--
the $500 one?
Exactly. That's
the more customized one.
That's $499. That's not where
we're gonna make our money.
That's not where
it's gonna happen.
Where are we gonna make
our money?
This is where
We're gonna make our money.
Where?
The same people that buy
the ADJUSTABLE basketball Courts
are gonna buy a retail version
of this for $199.
You know what I love about you?
You are the best salesman,
but this is your $500 model
We're looking at,
the guy
with the ugly face, right?
Yes.
Excuse me?
You're here not to sell us
on this,
but to sell us on a $200 model,
but we don't see it?
Well, that's why I'm here.
I'm going to show you--it's--
but there's no prototype.
It's not going to be
much different.
See, the thing about
this is--
why wouldn't it be, at half
the price, much different?
We can use less costly materials
to make that.
It's going to be smaller,
with shipping and boxing.
But that explains
half the money difference?
That doesn't make sense.
I love you, but I'm out.
Tony, I don't really see
the market, at that price point,
as a large consumer product.
I'm out.
I think it's a great idea,
but, literally, $500--
I know a guy in the Hood
that will guarantee...
(laughs)
To come to your house
every day
for the rest of your life
for $500 and guard you...
(laughs)
and yourentirefamily...
and he's tall.
(sharks laughing)
Okay. This is what
I need you to do, though.
You guys are all getting
caught up in the $500.
You're not l--you're not
listening to what I'm saying.
I'm out.
First of all, I think those are
the best-looking profenders
I've ever seen.
(laughs)
You've done a great job
with them,
but for me, the biggest question
is size of market,
and I think there's
a huge challenge, even at $200.
As a business, I don't see it.
I'm out.
Isn't the only guy on this panel
that you really need mark?
Mark, you can't go out on me.
Listen, I'm gonna tell you why.
This is Why. When I see you,
I see myself. I'm not lying.
When I see you,
I see myself.
You got a ton of money,
but money doesn't move you.
What moves you is
the journey to get there,
the push to get there.
That's what I'm about.
I'm gonna get there.
Mark, what are you
gonna do?
You know I love you,
everybody loves you, right?
Okay, listen,
before you go out...
okay.
'cause I hear
that going out...
(exhales deeply)
This is what you have
to understand.
With your help, it is going
to be on every driveway,
in every backyard, and it's
gonna be in every gym.
With my help,
it probably could be,
and that's one
of the unfortunate scenarios.
I don't have an unlimited number
of hours in the day.
I'd have to be able to call
the head coaches.
the athletic Directors.
Time is the most precious asset
that I have,
and unfortunately,
I don't see the reward.
For that reason, I'm out.
So Everybody's out?
All right, guys.
Dev, let's roll, son.
Absolutely I'm disappointed,
but just like I tell my son,
it's not whether you win
or lose.
It's, did you leave
everything you had
on the court or on the field?
Which I did.
♪♪♪
My name is Danny mastronardo,
and these are my brothers
and business partners.
We run
a successful family business
down here
in St. Petersburg, Florida.
Oh!
and when you see
four italian brothers,
you may think, a pizza shop,
a construction company
or something.
But in actuality,
we sell the world's best
skin care products.
We're a close-knit family,
and this business has
kept us together
and doing something that
we also love.
We make and formulate
all of our own products
in an office two minutes
from our parents' home.
We had an AMAZING response
from everyone Who's tried
our products,
and now our entire line
is available
at the most popular resort
in town, but that's not enough.
We know we've got a great
product that people love...
Hey, Gigi.
Gigi.
But we need the resources
to get it out there
and put it on a mass level.
We need help.
The sharks can give us
that investment that we want,
but more importantly,
be a mentor
and a partner that we need.
The brothers are
totally committed to making
Nardo's natural
a household name.
When the sharks see
our perseverance and passion,
they're gonna want to join
the Family.
Look out, sharks.
The nardo Brothers are
coming to you.
♪♪♪
Hi. My name is K.J.,
and these are my older brothers,
Danny, Kyle, and D.J.
We're the four brothers
behind Nardo's natural
organic skin care.
(Danny)
We are asking for $75,000
in exchange for 12%
of our company.
Nardo's natural is
an organic skin care line
With Ingredients derived
from nature.
We established nardo's natural
in 2009 and developed
our first moisturizer
in our kitchen.
Our organic products are used
during spa treatments
and also available
in retail
for consumers to take home
with them.
It is time to experience the spa
in the comfort of your own home.
And when you purchase
nardo's natural,
you become part of the family,
and you take the brothers
home with you.
(Robert and daymond laugh)
Very cute, guys.
My Oldest brother D.J.
Has a few products
to hand out for you guys.
Well, I know my wife
is gonna love this pitch.
(Kyle and Danny chuckle)
Everybody loves our pitch.
Thank you.
I-I just gotta know.
(chuckles)
Four good-looking,
normal guys...
(mastronardos chuckle)
How do you get
in the skin care business?
Well, D.J.'s our oldest brother,
and he toured the country
doing
a better health cooking show.
One day he burned himself
in front of a live show
in albuquerque, new mexico.
Our mother is a wound care
certified specialist,
so he called her up.
She said, "Well, what were
you doing over there?"
he goes, "I'm cooking
with Organic oils."
She said, "Okay, when
the burning sensation goes away,
"Put Those organic oils
on your skin.
It's gonna soothe
and hydrate."
A couple days later,
he's like, "This is fantastic.
I really thought
of something here."
He called upon the brothers,
and we reconvened,
and we all went down
to Florida
and said, "Let's start
a skin care line."
(laughs)
We bottled our first jar
in our kitchen,
and, uh, we literally
delivered across the street
after we had licensed
OUR business legally.
Are you guys gonna tell us
how much you've sold
of this stuff since 2009?
We actually have $30,000
to date of sales.
And you're
in one location now?
We're in several locations
right now, but we decided to--
how many is several?
How many is several?
17.
How much do you have
invested in the company?
Over $35,000.
And what are you guys doing now?
Each one of you guys have a job?
I am full-time with
the business, as well as Danny.
The other two brothers--
Keith--
I work in corporate America.
I'm providing
the cash flow to s--
to keep this company afloat.
How do the two of you live
on that small income, $30,000?
We actually--we are comfortable
to live for a year and a half
without taking any money
from our business.
How big do you think
you can be,
and what's it gonna take
to get there?
We're gonna project
$4.8 million in 2 years.
How many?
Mm.
$4.8 million
fr--two years from today.
Whoa.
Let me just tell you,
project--
from--from $30,000
to $4.8 million?
Uh, exactly. I'll explain,
if you don't mind.
Walk us through
how that's gonna happen.
We are planning
to land 100 accounts in 2 years.
Listen, I don't want
to give you bad news here,
but I'm gonna tell you
something.
There are thousands
of Nardo's out there.
Why is it gonna beyou
that they select?
Why not somebody else?
We're already being requested
for more accounts right now
we cannot supply.
And can you tell me what it
costs you to make that product
and what you sell it for?
An average cost--
the average markup
on each product is 600%.
Kyle, the margins are
incredible,
but--but here's my issue
with it.
You got four guys that look
like a singing group...
(k.J. Chuckles)
Waiting for that.
Terrible voices.
(laughs)
Now if I may interject
just a moment, uh,
we are four workhorses,
and that's what you're getting.
You're getting a package
of four in one,
but also, as I said,
we're gonna hit up, uh,
over a hundred accounts.
In those two years,
we did the math.
That's 7.3 Days.
Basically, if each of us can
close one account a month...
that's one account.
Look, let me--let me
give you some reality.
You've had a year.
You've only sold
$30,000 worth in that year.
Why haven't you sold
those hundred businesses?
Why next year instead
of this year?
We just don't have the capital
to actually manufacture.
We need $75,000 just to produce
the product. That's all--
but have you gone to a bank
at all? Have you tried--
Yes.
Do you guys have
credit cards?
We've gone to a bank
for personal credit cards.
We've been turned down.
(Kevin) No bank is gonna lend
these guys any money.
That's why they're in
the shark tank.
Exactly, but nobody's getting
money in this depressed economy.
What is the most brutally
competitive industry on earth?
Cosmetics. Do you know why?
There's only one other guy
that has better margins,
and that's a drug dealer,
all right?
(chuckles)
You've got to get this brand
out there.
You need millions of dollars.
How is that gonna happen?
That $4.8 million in sales is
a hundred accounts in 2 years.
That's one brother a month
landing an account.
Kyle, you keep--you know what?
You keep saying...
very Achievable.
"A hundred accounts.
A hundred accounts."
How many businesses you think go
from $30,000 to $4.8 million?
So let me ask
the--the zillion-dollar
question.
How much do you have
in unfilled orders?
Uh, a few thousand Dollars.
$6,000.
Oh, man, Kyle.
Okay, listen,
that's a bad number.
Because they will not land
until we can perform.
If we don't have the product,
they won't come through with us.
If this c--if this product
was so phenomenal
that everybody was
demanding it
and it was flying off
the shelves,
someone would reach
into their pocket.
I'm out.
What's that?
(Kyle) These are
testimonials from people
who have experienced
our product.
This is a-a letter
for 1600 pennsylvania ave.
The president
and the first lady
thanked us
for a wonderful product.
Let me see that.
(snorts)
Okay, let me read this.
(chuckles)
"The White House, Washington.
We would like to extend
"Our deepest thanks
and appreciation
"For your generous gift.
"We hope you will continue
to stay active and Involved.
Thank you again
for your kind gift."
(Robert) What does that mean?
This isn't--
"Please send $2,000
for my reelection."
(mark laughs) Yeah. Exactly.
This is totally generic, guys.
(Barbara) Absolutely.
Well, guys, let me--
let me just--
it means they're polite.
Let me just say something.
Uh, I believe in your story
as the four individuals,
because when I started, it was
myself and three other guys.
The beauty of it was,
at any given time,
four of us was someplace doing
something for the company,
and I think that that
was the basis to my success.
But, you know, I think
it's a little too early, uh,
so with that being said,
I'm out.
I'd like to tell you
what I don't like
about your business.
(Kyle) Sure.
Your projection
of $4.8 million in sales
with no justification,
really, on how
you could possibly get there,
really makes us
have to be almost a little
foolish to believe.
I respect that.
The other is, I don't like
your name, "Nardo,"
to be honest with you.
Well--
(Barbara)
Is that your last name?
No, our full last name
is Mastronardo.
That's even worse.
(men laugh)
No, you know, there's--
something about "Nardo" Sounds--
Yeah, that is bad.
It goes--uh, forgive me,
but it's not your real name,
so I don't feel bad
telling you.
And last, you know what I love?
Your stupid naivete.
(chuckles)
I've never seen
a young entrepreneur succeed
without great naivete,
and for that,
I'm gonna make an offer.
The contingency is...
okay, wait.
Before you make an offer...
wait.
Let me make an offer.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out,
and the mastronardos have
an offer on the table
from Barbara.
(Barbara)
The contingency is...
(Kevin) Okay, wait.
Before you make an offer...
wait.
Let me make an offer.
I'm gonna give you nothing.
You have no sales.
You don't even have
good packaging.
There's nothing proprietary
or unique about this product.
You are gonna get slaughtered.
I'm out.
May I continue?
Barbara, I forbid you.
You must be kidding.
There's nothing here.
$75,000 for 50% of the business
is with the contingency
that you at least remain open
to changing the name,
'cause as a marketing play,
I think the name's all wrong.
Wait a minute, Barbara.
There's a paragraph I missed
in this letter
from the president.
"Dear Barbara,
you're an idiot."
(Barbara and Robert laugh)
(Robert) B-before you consider
Barbara's offer,
I gotta tell ya,
what I love about you guys
is you're young,
you're passionate, you love it.
I mean, I love that.
What's this business worth
today realistically?
This thing's at $600,000,
$650,000, within that range,
and then there's Leverage.
That's Insane. That's insane.
(Kyle) We're not asking
for your money for a handout.
We just need a little bit
of work, and, uh, trust me--
man, I love you guys.
We got some drive, man.
I--but--
so make them an offer.
I-I can't...
(exhales deeply) I c--
(Danny)
give it to him, Keith.
Show him the face.
(sharks laugh)
please?
It's a great face.
Uncle Robert.
(chuckles) "Uncle Robert."
You're part
of the family now, Robert.
I can't do it
with the value.
I... I'm out.
(Kevin) You're down to Barbara.
You've got an offer--
$75,000 for 50%
of your business.
I think she's being way
too generous.
I would never offer you that.
But what are you gonna do
with it?
Why don't we go take
a minute?
Can we just take a minute?
(daymond and Kevin)
Take a minute.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
(exhales deeply)
All right, guys.
We're in a situation here...
come on.
And we have to really
pay attention and focus
on what we want to do.
Huddle.
Listen, this is--
We've put a lot of time...
guys--
and energy
into this product.
Half our business, man?
That's a lot, guys.
Need to really be smart
about this.
Try one counteroffer
and see what she says.
Well, if she'll listen.
What if she--what if she says
$100,000 at 50%?
She's willing--
she's willing to open up.
I can't wait.
I hope they take the deal.
I can't wait to show you
they're gonna succeed.
Those are great guys,
but I'm just--Barbara--
and that's why
they'll succeed.
(all)
one, two, Three. Nardo's!
All right, guys,
So Barbara offered you $75,000
for 50% of the business.
And we've, uh, taken
a few minutes to really Think
about that...
and we welcome you
to the Family.
Wow. Great.
Come on down here!
(mark) Congratulations.
(daymond) All right.
You won't regret it.
(speaks indistinctly)
(speaks indistinctly) Cool.
Thank you so much.
We don't shake hands.
We hug.
You feel better than
you look.
Yeah. (chuckles)
You're family now, so...
I-I need a squeeze a day.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
(mark and daymond)
Good luck, guys.
(Kyle and k.J.) whoo!
There we go, baby.
Go on and take that, homey.
Nardo's alive.
That was awesome.
Barbara, are you gonna make them
take their shirts off
and do a calendar?
No, I'm not that type.
(laughing)
No, she'll just make 'em
take their shirts off
and not do the calendar.
Cut it out, guys.
Gettin' dirty.
Oh, Barbara.
You just blew $75,000.
No, I didn't.
I can't wait
to show you, Kevin.
When we went through
with the deal
and Barbara came on board
and there were
four brothers here,
we were like, "Let's welcome
a sister into the group."
It was the BEST feeling ever.
♪♪♪
In season 1, we watched
Brett and Heath strike a deal
with Barbara Corcoran for
their pork barrel bbq sauce.
We'd love to accept
your offer.
Great.
(man) and when we first checked
in on them,
they broke ground on their
pork barrel bbq Restaurant.
(cheering)
Let's eat.
(man)
Let's see where they are now.
(Brett) We're minutes away
from opening the doors
for the first time
on pork barrel bbq restaurant.
All right, Buddy.
Let's do this.
We've been cooking all night.
Really, really excited
to have
our family and friends here.
I like the barbecue.
I like to eat it so much.
I mean, the line...
(chuckles) I can see it.
The line is so far
out the door.
We just can't wait to invite
them in for the first time.
(cheering)
You know, you work so hard
to create your dream,
and we just hope that people
love it as much as--as we do.
(both) Ohh.
(man) Thank you.
That's good, so good.
Before we got a deal
with Barbara,
we were running this company
out of my basement.
Now our sauces are carried
nationwide
in safeway, whole foods,
Costco.
Who is it?
(high-pitched female voice)
Hello.
Who is it?
Aah!
(laughs)
Did you guys think
I was gonna miss your big day?
It's been, you know, a meteoric
rise for pork barrel bbq,
and it's all thanks to Barbara
making a deal with us.
These were
two obnoxious little attorneys
in Washington, D.C.
With a dream...
(chuckles)
and they took
my little $50,000 investment,
and they turned it into
a hugely successful business.
We're in over 2,000 stores
in 40 states.
We've had over $1 million
worth of sales.
We have
our restaurant opening.
Barbara's been
an amazing partner.
Let's toast
these american hustlers.
(cheering)
♪♪♪
Next up is Todd Colby pliss,
whose business values
experience over Youth.
Hi. My name's
Todd Colby pliss,
and my company is
a revolutionary new Concept
in Quality
domestic staffing Needs.
Introducing rent-a-grandma.
(sharks laugh)
I am looking for $150,000
for 20% of my business.
Has this ever happened
to you--
you've hired a kid from down
the street to babysit
only to find out that texting
is the focus of their day,
rather than your child?
This is not
the best solution,
and you should not have
to settle for it.
Wouldn't it be great
to have a Loving caregiver
just like your grandma,
one who's--
one who concentrates...
(chuckles)
On thekids
and not electronics?
And who knows? Maybe she
can even bake Cookies.
Thank you, grandma.
(Kevin) Thanks, Granny.
Nana, you shouldn't have.
(woman chuckles)
Perfect.
(mark and daymond)
Thank you.
After hearing Horror Story
After horror story,
I knew there had to be
a better way,
and I thought to myself,
who's the most experienced,
who's the most trustworthy
when it comes to watching
the children, the households,
and, yes, even baking
delicious cookies?
And it hit me---
grandma on all counts.
Which would you rather have,
this... or this?
Don't ask daymond.
(chuckles)
How long have you been
in business?
Well, we've been in business
since late last year.
We have about 50 grandmas
in Los Angeles.
(chuckles)
Uh, we're getting
an incredible amount
of calls and e-mails,
uh, from around the country.
Word of mouth is spreading,
people that want to hire
grandmas.
It's been
pretty overwhelming.
What's your office like?
Do you have a bunch of grannies
sitting around drinking scotch
and smoking...
(laughing)
(laughs)
Waiting to get assignments?
(continues laughing)
Uh, not quite like that.
Todd, what are your sales today?
Our sales so far this year
have been about $25,000,
but we just had all
our disclosure documents done
for the franchises.
What does a granny get paid?
What's a granny going for
these days?
It depends what
they're gonna do.
I'd say, here in Los Angeles,
it's about...
anywhere from $14 to $20.
Other cities
it might be a little lower.
But what are babysitters
charging, so I can compare?
Oh, okay. Babysitters are
usually getting
anywhere from, like,
$10 to $13.
So grannies are
more expensive?
Yeah, but you're getting
decades of experience.
Most of them are
actual grandmas.
They know how to handle
situations.
They're really wonderful
with the kids.
So how can I make a buck off
of granny? How does this work?
Our clients sign
a placement agreement with us,
and we're getting a fee
up-front.
We charge
between 12% and 15%
of what the granny's
gonna get paid.
So you're saying We're only
getting 15% of Granny's take?
Uh, Well, yeah, but you're
being paid up-front
for whether
it's six months or--
you know, I gotta tell you
something, Todd.
That sounds, like, really thin.
You're actually acquiring
the customer,
and you're only making 15%.
Well, in the industry,
it's usually about 12% to 15%,
and don't forget,
once they're placed,
we're really not doing
a lot.
The response has
just been--
we have literally,
in the last two months,
got in over 400 requests
for franchise information.
But Why would anybody
franchise something
with only $25,000 in sales?
That doesn't make sense
to me, Todd.
What value do you bring?
There's no brand rent-a-granny.
I've never heard of this
before.
We're trademarked, and that's
'cause we're brand-New.
Well, now let's just punch
some numbers, Todd.
Average Babysitting session--
five hours.
Top-in Grannie--20 Bucks.
Get $100.
My Vig's 15%.
I make 15 bucks off of granny.
That's not enough.
I gotta squeeze granny big-time.
I need more dough.
Right, and that's exactly
what I was gonna say.
We're--our placements
are usually
6 to 12 Months or longer...
so we're charging
for the year,
and there's a minimum,
so our--
Todd, the margin on granny
sucks.
Whoa. Wait, wait, wait.
Kevin, let him finish.
Kevin, Kevin, Kevin.
15 bucks a day. He's--he's--
yeah, but let me tell you,
Kevin,
we're getting paid a minimum
up-front,
so it's not just
the $10 a day.
You're getting $1,200 to $2,400
from the, uh, client that's--
that's hiring the Granny.
Right.
Todd, what is
your minimum commitment
from the client?
If it's a temporary,
which means 90 DAYS or less,
we're usually gonna get
at least $1,200.
What happens
if the granny quits
or dies halfway
through the assignment?
(laughs)
Okay,
in our placement agreement,
we have
a replacement guarantee.
We will, uh, replace them
with up to three grandmas,
so if someone doesn't work out
for some reason...
(laughs)
(chuckles) Granny dies,
and in comes a new one...
if granny drops dead...
like the pet,
like the family pet?
Or the kids--
the kids stuff her
in the trunk...
(sharks laughing)
"Myrtle, put your wig on.
I got a job for you."
We're gonna--
we're gonna send out
three more women--
you don't need to finish that,
because with That--
cute idea. I'm out.
Okay, but, uh, you know,
with our franchises--
look, Todd.
You're doing $25,000.
You're a long way away
from franchising.
I'm out.
Todd, I think you have
a, uh, a smart name.
I love the name.
Thank you, and that's
trademarked, by the way.
Really clever,
but I have to say, this just
isn't my type of business.
I'm out.
Okay.
I just don't like
the numbers, Todd.
If you came back
and said to me,
"look, I can get granny
for 50 cents on the dollar,"
now you're talking.
(chuckles)
then I'd be interested,
but you're not, so I'm out.
I think you have a good idea.
I actually like it.
I think it's a brand
you can build,
but it's gonna be
very difficult to scale...
(chuckles) and honestly
I don't want to be in
the rent-a-grandma business,
um, so I'm out.
Okay. Thank you, gentlemen.
Good luck, Todd.
Thank you.
Good luck.
Appreciate it.
All the best.
You have to admit one thing.
He found
an UNTAPPED labor Force.
Unless you franchise this
very, very quickly...
but I don't want to be
that early,
'cause it's gonna take
a lot of work.
That insurance--
That's way too early.
♪♪♪
(gulls cry)
I'm Rachael Mann,
and this is my sister
and business partner
Mackenzie Burdick...
and We're the creators
of litter jewelry
in San Francisco, california.
Growing up, we were always
creating and designing together.
We were always
really into fashion.
Maybe out
of different materials?
I studied interior design,
and Mackenzie studied
fashion design.
You know, we've always
just been creators.
Creating is just in our blood.
It's what we love to do.
(Mackenzie)
Making custom Jewelry
just kind of fell
into our laps.
I really wanted to create
a unique piece of jewelry
that would really make me
stand out for a special event,
and so I broke up
a necklace
and wore it in my hair
as a headpiece,
and the response was
unbelievable.
So we made 50 more,
and we entered them
in a trunk show here
in San Francisco
and sold out of
every single one of them.
And that's
when litter began.
We take vintage chain
and broken pieces
of costume jewelry,
and we make pieces
of body jewelry.
Our entire business is
just the two of us,
and we are working
around the clock...
pouring the resins,
sourcing the materials,
making all the original
hand molds in my Backyard.
Mackenzie's got
a New baby coming.
I have a young son.
We need somebody to come in
and just help us manage
all of this.
That's why we need
the sharks.
We need somebody who can focus
on the business side,
so that we can get
back into the creative area
and making new Collections.
We really want to be able
to capitalize
on a trend that we created.
♪♪♪
Hi, sharks. I'm Mackenzie,
and this is my sister Rachael,
and we're litter.
We're san Francisco-based
jewelry and accessory designers.
We're here today seeking
$80,000
in exchange for a 51% stake
in our company.
Litter was started in 2009
when I broke up a necklace
and wore it in my hair
as a headpiece.
We were approached
by a friend
to make many more
of those headpieces
and sell them
in a local jewelry Show.
Rachael and I went around
to all the flea markets,
vintage stores,
Thrift stores in our area
and collected up chain.
We made 50 headpieces
and sold out at 150 bucks a pop.
With the money from the show,
we got a studio,
some materials,
and launched our web site.
Right away,
our designs were in demand,
and by 2010, we were selling
wholesale to retailers globally.
So we make headpieces,
ear cuffs,
jewelry that goes down
your legs,
which is just so sexy,
shoe jewelry, which can totally
transform the look of any shoe,
arm jewelry,
hands, which are awesome,
and we even make
chain mustaches.
(Robert and daymond laugh)
(Barbara) Oh, my God.
Why?
(laughs)
Paparazzi shields.
Paparazzi shields is
what we--
oh, wow.
No. They're great. Girl--
people at festivals,
music festivals--
they absolutely love them,
so...
our designs have
been featured
in all of
the top fashion magazines.
We've been worn by celebrities,
and all of this exposure
we got without one single dollar
being spent
on any advertising or P.R.,
and so we think
this is a perfect example
of how much bigger Litter
would get
if we had more TEAM members
managing our growth
and focusing
on aggressive sales.
How big is litter now?
What were sales last year?
What are they gonna be
this year?
Last year our sales were
$78,000,
and this year We're on track
for $150,000.
Why are sales so small?
I mean, this stuff is unique.
I haven't ever seen it before,
but only $150,000?
We're handmaking every single
piece ourselves right now,
and we just--
so how--
how much does
a typical piece cost,
and what's
your most expensive piece?
$100.
The average price is $100,
around $100.
And then what does it cost
you to make one?
About $2.
I have never seen a piece
like that.
This one?
That's, like, basically,
uh, chain mail,
for argument's sake.
Well, this--this piece
We're really proud of. We--
this took us a few hours
to make,
$20 in material,
and we just sold it
at a gallery for $1,600.
$1,600?
$1,600.
This is an example
of the kind of custom work
that we do for celebrities,
music videos.
Yeah.
We've been pulled
for, like, ke$ha, Ciara,
lady gaga,
and so that's like a--
what--do you have now--
I'm just trying
to understand this.
Do you have pending orders
that...
(Rachael) We do.
You can't keep up with?
Well, we just got picked up
by urban outfitters, and, um...
mm-hmm.
(Robert chuckles)
They are having us design
an EXCLUSIVE collection
for them.
And is there a minimum order,
Rachael, with them?
Are they guaranteeing
a certain order quantity?
Right now, it's a 400-piece
order and it's growing each...
Yeah, we have a 400-piece P.O.
And so it's gonna be a set?
And they're gonna see how
it goes, if it sells through?
(Rachael and Mackenzie)
Yes, exactly.
And go from there.
And you guys are making
everything by hand?
Everything.
That's craziness, right?
Every piece by Hand.
So can somebody else
make these
or does it require that special
touch that you guys have?
Other people can make them.
Nope, the designs are set by us,
and then from there,
other people can
take it from there.
I'm trying to figure out
how to ramp this up.
'cause, I mean, it's hip,
it's--it's fashion.
You're the designer babes.
You need somebody behind you
or in front of you
that's selling this...
(Rachael) Absolutely.
And getting huge orders.
We would like the money
to go towards
hiring a great salesperson
and then maybe getting us
a great P.R. Agency that just
constantly is pushing us.
But--but wait a second. You've
done all this without any P.R.
I like that model.
Yeah, but think how much bigger
it could get.
Get back to manufacturing.
If I send one piece over to--
to a manufacturer,
is there any reason he can't
pound out 10,000 of them?
No.
There's no reason.
So you wanna work for somebody.
We're just looking for
the right partner
that knows what they're doing.
Yeah.
We just need to know the next
steps to take, you know?
It's just gotten bigger than us.
You guys are designers. That's
your special sauce, right?
Yeah, that really is
our special sauce.
And you guys wanna design.
Exactly.
And anything else that you do
takes your time away
from Designing.
Exactly.
So you want someone
to come in and say,
"guys, you do what you do,
right?
We'll take over the rest."
(Rachael and Mackenzie) Mm-hmm.
The challenge is--
here's kind of the catch-22.
We can't just come in
and work full-time, right?
No. Exactly. Exactly.
So you have to hire somebody
to come in and work full-time.
We understand,
mm-hmm.
Tell us how you would spend
the $80,000.
What--what do you have
envisioned?
I would like to hire a really
great salesperson initially,
and then also just ramp up
our web site.
Our web site could be
1,000% better.
Be able to handle
high--higher Volume.
Yeah.
Again, we all know
it's gonna take
more than $80,000 long run,
but initially, we think
that would be a good start.
You guys are walking proof of
concept. That's what happened.
You sold just enough
to make it interesting...
(Robert) right.
But not enough
to say it's a business.
Right.
I mean, it is so
on the tipping point
because you should be getting
$150,000 orders from somebody,
not $150,000 a year.
We need somebody
that is in sales
that has those department store
connections and web site--
I don't--I don't--I don't know
what to do with you guys.
I mean, I-I can give you money,
but I don't want to work
at your shop.
Yeah, I understand.
I want you to bring me
a package that says,
if you give me $180,000,
$250,000,
I can turn this into
a $10 million business.
Here's my plan.
Right.
If you told me that,
I'd probably
be very, very interested.
Because I like the stuff...
mm-hmm.
I like the story,
and I like you guys.
And I don't say that
very Often.
Can--
(chuckles) Thank you.
I should be beating you
with stick
for making the mistake
you've made.
But with your money,
we could be able to
spend less time hand-making each
piece and being able to fill--
no, I don't want you to
hand-make anything. I want you
to get somebody in China
to make 10,000 copies of it.
Exactly.
I-I don't have the passion
for the jewelry business...
(Rachael) Okay.
And I have a full-time job.
I-I-I can't help you find
that person.
I'm out.
All right.
What's the most popular piece
there
that sells the most?
Our leg chains
are really popular.
Mm-hmm.
Um, yeah.
What about that?
Is there another one
of a leg chain like that?
Yeah, this is called
a slim garter.
How much
does that sell for?
$120.
I'll take that. All right?
Do you have it in his size?
(Kevin) I want that
right off your leg.
What about the beard?
Can I see one of the beards?
I'd love to.
(Rachael) Yes, of course.
So you might have to, uh,
put these on.
Does that work?
As you put it on,
you have to kind of adjust it.
(laughs)
(Kevin) He can go incognito
tonight.
(laughter)
That is so perfect for Kevin.
You're putting it
on the wrong guy.
That is cool.
(Robert)
daymond, what are you doing?
Well, you...
okay, so here's the deal.
This is basically
what we call in Our business
a designer offer.
And the designers normally,
the top end of a deal
is they get 35%
because they're
just designers.
Now I will give you
the $80,000...
for 70%.
(Barbara) 70%?
But what if we're willing
to do the work? Like...
then I will let you
buy back in
to acquire what
you initially asked for.
$80,000 for 70%. Wow.
(Kevin)
it doesn't make any money.
(Barbara)
You know, daymond, you w--
(daymond) it does make money.
You would never make that offer
to a male designer. No way.
Ohh. No, come on.
Oh, here comes her crap.
Whoa! B-Barb...
say what you want.
Look, guys--guys, here's part
of the challenge.
It's the truth.
And I'm gonna
sell myself here.
Part of this challenge is,
now you still have to figure out
how to pay yourselves.
No, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Excuse me.
So it's $80,000
for 70% of your company.
But you will also
get salaries as well.
So you'll have salaries
and you'll have profit.
Well, you better ask
about the salary, girls.
(Rachael and Mackenzie) Yeah.
It better be a lot to make up
for what he's taking from you.
We would have to agree on it.
I mean, I would think--
what's a typical designer make,
daymond?
What kind of salary
are you willing to pay us?
It all depends
on--on the business.
A typical designer ranges
from $50,000 to $250,000.
(Robert) That's a big range.
Exactly.
We wanna be on the higher end.
Yeah, no kidding, right?
It all depends
on the designer.
I think that's all
in the details,
but right now,
what I'm willing to is
$80,000 for 70%.,
make you guys
the head designers.
If you want and you feel
you can run the company,
I'll go right back down
to the 51%.
Don't till you know
you have other offers coming.
But unfortunately, if you
entertain the other offers,
I'm gonna pull back.
Whoo.
♪♪♪
One shark is out.
Daymond has made an offer
of $80,000 for a 70% stake
and an annual salary
for Rachael and Mackenzie.
But he has also said
that he will back out
if they entertain
anyone else's offer.
Whoo.
(mark) Let me talk to this guy.
Daymond, what if we did this?
$40,000 each. I'll deal with
the Web site side of it.
I don't think
you've nailed down a salary.
That's a broad range
of Salaries.
Barbara, what do you think?
Rachael, Rachael, Rachael.
Mark just--
I can't get a word in.
Mark just offered
to come in half with me,
and he'll handle
the Web site side...
the Web site side.
And the internet marketing.
And I'll handle
the manufacturing
and the retail side.
So his strength is
the retail, manufacturing.
Mine is the internet--
internet marketing,
social media.
You'll get
the best of both worlds.
By the way, I know the president
of urban outfitters,
and I work with
the number one guy
who provides 80%
of ll the jewelry...
mm-hmm.
In America.
(Barbara)
Rachael, come over here.
All right, just to
make things interesting.
And to help you
'cause I love you guys,
um, I'll just do
the deal you want.
I'll give you the $80,000
for 51%, and I don't bring
any of the expertise
in the jewelry business at all.
(laughs)
the one thing you said
you needed.
And I admit that because
I'm honest about it.
I'm a financial investor.
But what connections are you
gonna put us in line with
That are gonna help us?
More money.
I hate to do it, but I'm gonna
give you what mark usually does,
is--what is it,
a 24-second clock?
Oh, the 24-second clock?
No, you're not gonna give it.
Hold on a moment, girls.
(sharks all shouting at once)
We've seen this routine before.
To clarify it, I'm giving you
a 24-second time clock.
Rachael, listen to me.
Mark and I are coming in
at $80,000.
Half and half. You will
also get salaries...
let me tell you what
I'm going to give you.
And he will handle internet,
and I will handle Retail.
Please, he's gonna try
to close it down
so you don't get a better bid.
I'm gonna start your 24-second
time clock right now.
Tell him to take a walk. I'll
bring him in after the fact.
For 70% of the company.
Ay, yi yi.
Yes.
Thank you.
(laughs)
Oh, my God.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
(Barbara) What?!
(daymond) Congratulations.
(Barbara)
I'm gonna kill you!
(Rachael) Thank you, Barbara,
so much.
Not on my watch, Barbara!
(laughs)
What?!
we love you, Barbara.
Seriously, we really love you.
Too bad, girls.
(Rachael speaks indistinctly)
(mark) Thank you, guys.
Congratulations.
Thank you! Bye.
It's like watching the lambs
go to the slaughterhouse.
(mark) It's easy money.
Oh, my God.
You were vague,
you gave them a lousy deal.
Ay, yi yi.
Ooh, ooh! Ooh, ooh!
He's gonna wear that out.
That--that's all I need.
(laughing)
We went in there wanting to be
partners with Daymond and mark.
I mean, those were
our two Favorites.
Those were the ones we went for
and, gosh, we got it,
and we're just feeling
amazing.